[Music]
it's essentially the district planning
handbook that manages a bunch of
activities including residential zonings
rural zonings and business zonings other
things such as road widths building
heights and subdivision
[Music]
the current district plan is nearly 20
years old it's really important
addresses the right things because it
will affect most people in some way
waimakariri district's been a really
fast growing district over the last 20
years
it's important that the new district
plan addresses current issues but also
future issues not only urban issues but
matters to do with the natural
environment and the rural environment as
well
the new plan has a number of key changes
particularly around zones number of new
zone descriptions and new provisions to
do with ewe and also things such as
natural hazards importantly the new plan
will look quite differently than it does
now it will be all online which will
make it much more accessible for you to
use
we want to hear from you through the
submissions process so that you can
introduce new ideas to the plan or help
us refine existing ideas as part of the
proposed plan we really encourage you to
come and talk to our planner one of our
talk to the planning sessions and also
look up your property online as part of
the e-plan if you need any further
information or would like to talk to us
get in touch
you